[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the President of the United
States and the vice president of the
United States have planned and executed
a cheap cynical political stunt which
disrespected exploited and desecrated
the flag of this country it was a stunt
so degrading to what this nation means
and who Americans are that the president
and the vice president should resign in
shame the vice president mr. pence acted
as if he was offended at San Francisco
49ers football players who knelt during
the national anthem left their game and
then tweeted in high and condescending
dudgeon about why he left and how he
would not dignify the event and it was
all part of a sleazy political stunt the
president this baboon Trump then not
only took credit for Pence's supposedly
spontaneous political tactic but made
pence out as a liar by boasting that he
had asked pence to leave the stadium and
thereby confirmed that both the action
and Pence's tweet were all part of a
sleazy political stunt and an
unidentified aide to pence then revealed
that for once
Trump who claims credit for the actions
of others or the outcomes of life so
often that you could predict its
likelihood as part of a weather report
was in this case not lying the pool
reporter accompanying pence to the
Indianapolis stadium was told to stay in
the press van because to quote a CNN
reporter that the vice president would
leave the game early the unidentified
aide might as well have handed out a
press release that said pence and this
water buffalo Trump had scheduled down
to the minute all the parts of a sleazy
political stunt this issue of athletes
kneeling or locking arms or raising
fists during our national anthem is no
longer merely about their correct
protest of those police who have lost
their way in dealing with the minorities
of this country this issue of athletes
protesting is now a smaller part of a
very big very hypocritical very
dangerous plan being undertaken by this
jackass Trump this falsely
hiya Spence and their toady's and
apologists and jackboots who support
them and would turn this democracy into
an authoritarian and homogenous state in
which they and Pence and Trump begin to
be equated with and to symbolize the
police
we're protesting the police will get you
publicly vilified they would turn this
healthily argumentative Republic into an
authoritarian and homogeneous state in
which they and Pence and Trump begin to
be equated with the national anthem
we're failing to stay at attention
during the anthem will get you fired
from your job and they would turn this
spectacularly diverse and rich bastion
of freedom into an authoritarian and
homogeneous state in which they and
Pence and Trump begin to be equated with
the flag and failing to salute the flag
will get you beaten in the streets by
the kinds of scum who marched again in
Virginia Saturday night the kinds of
scum about which Vice President pence
said nothing this farce was a divisive
craven cynical desecration of our flag
for purely political purposes by people
who claimed they were protesting a
divisive craven cynical desecration of
our flag for purely political purposes
the national anthem is a song it's a
song the music to which was stolen from
something the English once sang in their
pubs while they got drunk if it
represents anything about America it
represents our right to sing along or to
stay silent but it is a song it is not
America the flag is a flag it is a piece
of cloth and many of the flags these
frauds Pence and Trump want you to stare
at as if they dispensed eternal life
were manufactured in other countries if
the flag represents anything about
America it represents our right to
protest it when those wrapping
themselves in it are doing wrong it is
just a flag it is not America and most
important of all protest is protest you
are not loyal or patriotic because you
stand during an old British drinking
song nor because you salute a flag that
might have
made in China you are loyal or patriotic
because you try to make this nation
better and to take action on its behalf
and do not say love it or leave it but
rather to say love it and improve it
this nation is built on protest and that
is so fundamentally true so important
and what pence interrupted was so
cynical and so unamerican
that their stunt was denounced by the
Indiana branch of the American Legion
since this dictator in training Trump
began to urinate on our flag and our
Constitution now using the Vice
President as the proverbial organ
grinder used to use the proverbial
monkey opposition to National Football
League players protesting has become
support by 51% to 42% opposition to how
Trump has threatened retaliation is more
than two-thirds but it is not for the
majority of this country that these
amoral curs Trump and pence pulled their
fetid little stunt on Sunday the message
behind the anti player crowd is the
football players are disrespecting the
flag the football players are mostly
African American the African Americans
are disrespecting the flag it is
divisive it is racist it is cynical it
is everything this country has fought
for 241 years to not become and it stops
here because the people disrespecting
the flag are not the athletes who see a
profound and painful and life-and-death
problem and seek by symbolism to stop it
and fix it and heal it the people
disrespecting our flag are Donald Trump
and Mike Pence and their clan of white
supremacists who see their chance to
whip up unthinking blind saluting white
robots into believing the flag is theirs
and theirs alone and this kind of race
baiting Donald Trump's kind of race
baiting will not be permitted in our
country we have been through this and we
will not let a hateful cynical stupid
demagogue like Donald Trump drag us back
into that cave of prejudice the flag
will stay the anthem will stay the right
to protest them both the players right
my right your right we
stay Donald Trump and this little clown
Mike Pence they will go resist remove
peace